[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAVIN BARRETT: The launch of the
family section on Google Play
was hugely positive
for StoryToys.
I think what it did
was solve the discovery
issue for parents.
EMMET O'NEILL: It's really
provided a safe, trusted,
creative space for families
to find new content.
SHARON RECHTER: My partner Guy
Oranim and I started BabyFirst
with the idea and the passion to
create good educational content
for babies, toddlers,
and their parents.
When we learned about
the family category
on the Google Play Store,
it was a 100% match
to the BabyFirst values.
We have seen that
parents can easily
find the content
they are looking for.
We now have 40% more
downloads on Google Play
than we do on other platforms.
We like that.
GAVIN BARRETT: Since the launch
of the family section on Google
Play, our experience
with Android
has been completely transformed.
We saw a huge
uplift in revenues,
and our downloads to
Google Play was now
our number one [? chart. ?]
It's been nothing but positive,
and we're delighted
to be involved.
[MUSIC PLAYING]